hello everyone and welcome to the one
million subscribers
milestone video featuring none other
than the magician from riga now those of
you who are new to the channel may not
know this but
uh the the great magician is uh uh well
sort of a sort of a sole protector of
this channel
he watches over us every day while we're
analyzing chess games you can see him
up there right above me above above the
fat chocobo
and uh whenever this channel hits a
milestone we show a nice game played by
the
by the magician here uh he faces a most
vile opponent
it's a russian grand master lev polo
pogevsky
and uh so far they've played four games
and all
all four games uh ended in a draw but
this one this one's a bit different
and polygavsky is one of those opponents
that misha couldn't really
uh play against as he couldn't be
tricked and misha often
liked to hypnotize people you know just
get them into time trouble complicate
complicate and complicate and then they
would blunder but not
uh grand masters such as polugawski here
or maybe paul karis or some
other very very strong grandmasters now
it's a very very exciting game
uh from 1959 a year you all know very
well due to the
1959 candidates tournament but this is
from the 1959 uh ussr
championship uh that featured uh and 19
of the of the
the absolute strongest uh players uh
imaginable but we're gonna we're gonna
discuss that a little bit later
so now uh we are going to check out the
game but for for those of you who are
interested i will show you the play
button
uh because it's uh quite large i did not
expect it to be so large so here are the
contents of the
of the youtube present that i received
yesterday uh so here it is this is a
letter
uh from the uh from the youtube ceo
susan uh you can't read it maybe you can
maybe you can't i don't know but
basically it says you know
congratulations on building such a nice
community on
uh achieving this milestone for for
being the greatest chess channel and so
on you know the
pretty usual stuff and here just to show
you
the difference between the the gold and
the silver play button uh here's the
silver play button
so this is the gentleman you will know
uh we you've seen this
uh received uh when the channel reached
100 000 subscribers so there you have it
it's you know of reasonable size you
know maybe a bit larger than my head
if you can if you can see but now check
out the the golden play button it's
really
really a monster and it's very heavy too
so let me just uh
okay that's a that's a really heavy dude
sorry about that all right there we go
all right look at this bad boy all right
this is the golden play button
there we go it's quite larger than my
head there oh
now you can even see my microphone there
we have it uh so yeah this is the golden
play button which you receive
when your channel on youtube reaches the
1 million subscribers i can't really get
it
away from the glare but ah there you
have it there you have it
presented to agatha for passing 1
million subscribers so it's quite a
large one
i never knew that the golden play button
is so large i always thought all of them
were
of the same size just different material
but it is it is quite a nice one and i
will
very very gladly i placed it on on my
wall in my
uh in my new recording studio that will
almost uh
that is almost fully operational uh that
being said i know uh
when i got the the previous one i said
i'm not gonna do any sort of unpacking
but i just wanted to show you this one
is
so large so that being said let's check
out this very nice game as this is what
we're here to do
so uh misha versus i love pologavsky
like i said this is their fifth game and
uh
tile opens with e4 as he usually does
uh we have c5 by poligovsky going for
the sicilian defense knight to f3
d6 and uh strikes uh in the center
uh as this is what you want to do with
the captures on d4 knight captures and
the knight to f6 so attacking the four
pawn
uh tal defends it and now a6 going for
the knight of
uh knight of defense with bishop to g5
and now
knight b to d7 the knight is coming to
c5 at some
point we have bishop to c4 by misha and
now
queen to a5 uh queen to b6 is also very
popular nowadays as this variation is
still being played
but queen to a5 was was the go to move
in those days putting pressure on the
bishop here on g5
and here just queen to d2 defending the
bishop on g5
uh and here polygams he played e6 and it
does make sense
uh you kind of want to weaken white
flight square bishop here and also you
want to
continue developing you have to play e6
the bishop seven castles and so on
uh but here uh uh again nowadays uh h6
would be
would be the good move as uh such a move
has been seen
for example in the game already versus
anton korobov in the 2019 world rapids
championship that that alireza won but
like i said instead here we have
e6 and now uh tall castles we have
castles bishop to e7 pologevsky also
prepares the castle
and now rook a to d1 still to this day
the the absolute top move rook a to d1
and
now comes knight to c5 and this is uh
this is already uh uh the beginning of
the end
i would say not not really the end but
here uh the position is still being
played today and h6
is the move that black wants to play
here after h6 then everything just falls
into order
uh bla white will either get get rid of
the bishop with
for example bishop to f4 and then you
shift the knight over to e5 attack the
light square bishop and so on
but here we have knight the c5 right
away and it seems like it's a good move
it puts pressure on the e4 pawn
and white needs to react to this uh
defends with rook f2 e1 and now we have
bishop to d7 so what do you play here
here the position is uh positionally the
position is lost for black
but it's not that easy to spot i will
just uh
ask you to pause the video here and try
to find the idea here it's a pretty
standard idea
when you play against the sicilian so uh
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the best move for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
uh spotting the the beauty and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
e5 is possible here but it's actually
knight to f5 knight to f5 and now you
have a triple attack on the d6 pawn and
the black needs to react to this
uh not capturing the knight doesn't
really do anything but
um you have to capture otherwise you're
just
gonna start losing material so here you
would have captures captures
and now the black king is stuck in the
center of the board you can't really go
anywhere otherwise the bishop will be
captured
so here you would have to go for
something like knight here uh try and
force a queen trade and
give back some material for example
knight captures on e4
queen captures on d2 knight captures on
f6 with
check g captures as the bishop is pinned
and now bishop captures back on d2
bishop captures on f5 and now bishop to
d5
uh going after this pawn also bishop to
f4 will be an idea going after d6 the
black king is still in the center of the
board
so it's a bishop pair versus bishop pair
but look at
white spawn structure and look at
black's pawn structure white spawn
structure is completely intact whereas
black's pawn structure that's four pawn
islands
uh that's uh that's pretty bad and with
with perfect play this is most
likely winning for white uh but tal had
a different idea todd did not go for
this
bishop for this knight to f5 move tal
instead
played a3 here so congratulations to
those who found this
not an engine favorite but uh if you
found the move that the magician found
then uh congratulations that's even
better than finding the engine's move
so here the thread is b4 just winning
the piece as it would come with a double
attack on the queen and on the knight
so queen back to c7 by polugawski and
now
b4 pushing the knight back we have
knight to a4
and now comes uh the beauty knight
captures on a4
and now of course you cannot capture on
c4 because knight to b6 just wins the
rook on a8
so you have to capture back we have
bishop captures on a4
and now we reach the position from the
thumbnail so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find
the move that uh tal played while i give
you a couple of seconds
one more time
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on sacrificing
something on e6 because that's what you
have to do doesn't really matter what
you sacrifice you have to sacrifice
something and here
uh top played bishop captures on e6 uh
and
it's interesting night captures on e6
also works but it's
it's like tom knew that it simply wasn't
enough to go for a win but it is super
exciting
uh okay now you have a question do you
capture the bishop or the knight if you
capture the bishop then it's game over
then just uh
knight captures on g7 with check king to
f8 and
now knight back to f5 and although it
looks like
it's playable it's really not here for
example queen captures on c2
uh going after this going after this
queen here
you just play bishop captures on f6 so
what do you play now
doesn't really matter for example queen
captures on d2 you're gonna capture on
e7 with
check uh or rather you don't have to but
if you play something like bishop
captures on f6 then you also allow queen
captures here and then it's even worse
so here uh after bishop captures we have
queen captures bishop captures on e7
with
check king to e8 and now you're just
gonna win back the queen
and then you're up a b so this is
obviously not playable so after knight
captures an e6 uh you
you cannot go after the bishop you have
to go after the knight so we would see
probably captures and captures
and now you get this position where the
black king is stuck in the middle the
bishop prevents castling
kingside or queenside and it's a it's a
trade-off a piece for
for two pawns that doesn't really even
uh i mean shouldn't even classify as a
as a sacrifice at least not by tal
standards
so here instead after bishop captures an
a4 now misha did not go for
knight captures rather he went for
bishop captures on e6 and this is a
little bit different
but the bishop has to be accepted
otherwise you're just down upon and
there's really no point in doing
anything
other than that uh for example you could
castle then
white just brings back the bishop and
it's a it's a
a terrible position for black because
black was hoping at some point with the
help of the e6 pawn to maybe execute d5
here
without the d6 pawn executing d5 is
never happening and
at some point white will simply have too
much pressure on the d
file and that pawn will be captured so
instead after bishop captures an e6 we
have
f captures on e6 accepting uh tall
sacrifice
and now comes knight captures on e6
attacking the queen the g7 pawn
and the black needs to find a move and
there is only one good move for
polugawski here and he finds it and
that's queen captures on c2
you have to move the queen so why not
move the queen with tempo the tempo of
course being you want to trade off the
queens and
enjoy your extra piece and now uh misha
goes for
queen to d4 interestingly knight
captures on g7 with
check is also possible but extremely
tricky i will show it however
that's why we're here it's uh it's quite
the game uh for example king to f7
attacking the knight queen to d4
sacrificing yet another piece
king captures on g7 and now rook to c1
and now
you will see what happens here black is
up two pieces but
it doesn't matter queen to b3 now e5
so what do you play here d captures on
e5 rook captures on e5
threatening the bishop also the rook is
coming to c7
so here uh black is completely lost and
unless
black finds queen to f7 queen to f7 only
move that saves polygavsky
and now uh tao would be able to go into
this crazy bishop to h6
check king captures an h6 and now queen
to e3
with check and also a double attack on
the bishop doesn't really matter
uh well it doesn't matter if you go king
g6 then you're even getting checkmated
with queen to g5
so you have to go up the board king to
g7 then rook captures and then you will
win the queen but
black is up too much material or maybe
maybe not
too much just enough for example rook 8
to d8
and now you can trade queens here
captures captures but it doesn't matter
black is very happy if rook to c7 check
you can simply block rook to d7 and
black
for example if if captures and captures
or even better with the knight with the
bishop
you have two pieces and a rook for the
queen and this is more than enough to
uh to fight white whites to a draw at
least
so instead after queen c2 we don't have
knight captures and g7 but
tal first prepares it with queen to d4
so here we have king to f7 again
is able to go for this knight captures
on g7 line and transpose into the line
that we've just discussed
but he goes rook to c1 he wants to shift
his rook over uh to the seventh rank
queen to a2 now attacking the knight
here
and now e5 offering this knight for uh
for
uh for counter play along the e file
poligavsky first captures uh on e5
as uh anything else it would be would be
extremely dangerous
so d captures an e5 queen captures on e5
and now we get this position where uh
i mentioned at the beginning of the
video usually uh tal defeated his
opponents by uh overworking them by
making them calculate by making them go
into time trouble
then they would blunder they would uh uh
you know uh start uh started getting
nervous
you know the position would get more
complicated and complicated but this
usually didn't work against players like
uh like polugawski here but here
uh it's almost as if it did work because
here
uh what you have to do is to go for this
very very unpleasant queen to d5 move
just uh
offering the piece back and there's
there's no better move here for black
now because then we go into bishop
captures on f6 now adding a defender
to the queen captures captures uh sorry
captures on e5 and now
king captures on e6 going in front of
the room but
there aren't all that uh great
discoveries here bishop captures and g7
yes this is possible but you're still
going to move and you're going to give
up the rook as well so bishop captures
the rook captures
and we would get this position where tal
would have two rooks but polygamy would
have a rook and the bishop
pair which is more than more than uh
sufficient to fight the rooks the bishop
can come to c6 this guy may be to d6 and
yeah you would be able to to play this
no problem
so this is what uh pologovsky had to do
in order to
survive this onslaught but he decided to
trade down into a different endgame
and played queen captures on f2 yep
that's the one that he played queen
captures on f2 with
check and now you have to capture or
maybe even you don't but
after let's say king to h1 then bishop
on c6 and suddenly it's white who's on
the it
it's it's black who's on the attack so
instead
after this queen captures on f2 uh tal
decided to capture the queen we have
king captures and now of course comes
the royal fork
knights the g4 checking the king and uh
also forking the queen with king to g1
and
knight captures an e5 so similar to that
we have rook captures on e5 and now
bishop captures on g5 uh you have to
capture with the knight if the rook
captures then the knight falls so knight
captures on g5 with
check and now king the g6 you have to go
after this very very unpleasant uh
square
uh uh because uh anything else simply
will not to do it
it will be too dangerous to allow any
checks so with this rook
along the seventh rank it's just gonna
be uh crushing so here
king to g6 still good because the the
king
still has the the uh defense of the g7
pawn here
and now while tal could go rook to c7
and there's nothing wrong with that he
first prepares it with knight to e6 now
rook to c7
could be very deadly as it would come
with a double attack we have rook h the
e8
by poligievsky and now misha goes rook
to e3
this is a sort of an attacking defensive
move because he doesn't want to allow
this to come with a double attack
so instead he goes back rook to e3 and
now
rook ate the c8 so it seems pologiveski
developed all of it all of his pieces
the bishop the bishop on a4 still needs
to find a good square
uh probably something like b5 or c6 in
the future will be
uh will be what uh what should be played
and here uh we have
rook to f1 by misha uh interestingly
going for rook to g3 check right away is
possible but you don't achieve anything
king f7 you're gonna capture on c8 the
rook captures rook captures and now
you're gonna capture on g7 yes you win a
pawn
but black wins it back very easily rook
to c1 with
check king to f2 rook c2 check you're
going to go king to e1
and now bishop to c6 and this is how
black wins back the pawn
uh or if white is persistent in
defending and then just uh
bishop to b5 check and we would probably
see a repetition of moves here
king e1 bishop attacks the pawn the king
goes back bishop here and so on and so
on
so here after rook 8 to c8 we do not
have such a such an idea
starting with rook to g3 but style
instead goes for
instead goes for this uh bishop to b5
sorry polgovsky goes for bishop to b5
town instead of rook to g3 went for rook
to f1
and now it's uh it's getting very
dangerous now the king is completely cut
off from the
f-file and rook to g3 could be could be
very problematic
so here we have bishop to b5 and here
bishop to d7 is the move that's missing
in all of the
lines that polugawski tries to defend
his position bishop to d7
is crucial uh because well you just need
it for example rook g3 check
came to h6 knight captures on g7 and now
you just play rook to f8
and everything is perfect now because
the bishop here
completely controls all of the squares
that the knight can use
to go back into the game so here the
knight is pretty much stranded on g7
and it's hard to say if white would be
able to do anything here a polygamy
however doesn't go for bishop to
d7 he goes bishop to b5 attack starts
rook on f1
and now rook to g3 with check we have
king to h6
and now again what do you play here here
tal went for
knight captures on g7 i know you're
probably
probably thinking why not look at four
with rook to h for checkmate well the
problem is
rook the c1 with check king f2 and now
rook to f1 with
check and all of white's pieces uh just
get
destroyed king e3 you're gonna get rook
captures here with
check and that's just it if rook here
even rookie one check
there is nothing to do you have to move
the king and then just rook captures
rook it's a
complete uh annihilation so here after
king to h6 we have
knight captures on g7 instead by misha
and now
rook to f8 uh so trying to cut that
knight off
from escaping and also offering a trade
of rooks along the f file
uh you could go for the rook with the
bishop captures an f1 it is possible but
uh the knight
captures rook here so it doesn't really
matter and then if after rook captures
king captures here
tal would go into this rook component
game being up upon uh which
probably isn't losing for pelogevsky but
poligovsky decides that he can do better
so he goes rook to f8 instead and now
comes
rook to e1 again what do you play here
we have rook to f6
very important you do not want to allow
rook to e6
and here tal goes for h3 very important
if you want to do any sort
of a rook lift to avoid that trick that
we've just seen rook to c1 followed by
rook to f1
check so here uh poligivski for for the
last time
needs to play bishop to d7 after bishop
to d7 everything
works out for him because even now rook
the e5 threatening checkmate with rook
the h5
uh does not win uh because of uh rook to
g6 and now everything is perfectly fine
you are attacking the rook attacking the
knight and there is no knight f5 check
because
bishop captures an f5 that's the beauty
of bishop to b7
however after h3 we have rooked the c2
by poligivski and
now the position is completely lost for
him
probably played due to time trouble uh
but
uh it it doesn't seem like uh
like like a reasonable move to do
especially
since he was defending but i don't think
he was aware of all the
mating threats uh because if he if he
had he'd probably
find bishop to d7 so this is pretty
crazy stuff
uh so here tal of course immediately
went rook to e4
uh for the for the fun of it i will show
how rook to e5 is also playable
uh now rook to g6 the move that we said
that works in the variation where the
bishop is in d7 doesn't work because now
misha has knight to f5 check king to h5
and now just
knight to e3 check a discovery winning
the rook here
so that's why that's why it doesn't work
it's completely hopeless now
for example a king here you can trade
with check and then just pick up the
rook and your position is completely
winning
so instead after rook to c2 we have rook
to e4
uh now going for this other checkmate
seems pretty
pretty uh straightforward but now
polygams
can defend with rook to c4 and he does
he now defends against checkmate
and only now tao shifts the rook over to
e5 now threatening rook to h5 checkmate
and hero poliwski probably realized that
he completely messed up i don't know the
the whole story of this game probably
polugawski
uh started spending his time too much
and then he missed
this um a lot of these ideas from uh
from tao but you know you you can't uh
avoid losing all of them like i said
this is their fifth game uh
ever uh and uh the first four ended in a
draw so here polygamy played rook to c1
with
check uh towel played king sir tal
played king to h2
and it was in this position on move 34
yes we are only at move 34 but we've uh
covered a lot of lines because it's it's
quite at the game
uh love polygey resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh once you tried this uh the only
defense basically that we
have uh you cannot prevent uh rook to h5
uh
both of these squares bishop to e2 that
cover that square and bishop the e8
that cover that square are covered by
the rook so the rook
prevents the bishop from helping out
with the defense so here uh if rook to
g6 like we said we just go into the
the this knight to f5 check king the h5
and now okay you don't have
uh knights the e3 check winning the road
because the rook is now on c1 but it
doesn't matter and this is what uh
polugawski probably missed um
when he went into all of this uh knights
the e7 check now wins this rook and
not only do you win the rook but after
king h6 and knight captures and g6h
captures
you get this rook the e6 move and now
it's not going to be you're not going to
be
just down one pawn and the exchange
you're going to be down two points in
the exchange and that's just uh
not playable at all uh because but the
rook uh
the rooks are defending all of these
squares that the bishop can defend
so you will not be able to to defend the
pawn anyway next move uh
dal will just capture the pawn
everything uh all of his spawns are
nicely defended and that's just it
so uh the first decisive game uh between
tal and polgovsky goes to
goes to uh the magician and what a game
it was
uh but i don't know if i mentioned at
the beginning of the video uh but in
classical games a lot pollution has a
pretty brutal positive score against uh
mikhail tal he defeated them eight to
two with
22 draws so uh out of all of those
32 games they played uh tal only one two
two games
this being this being one of them so as
you can see tao uh
if he couldn't work his magic against
you you you definitely had a chance of
of playing against him
uh sam uh quite the tournament and
interestingly tom did not
win it the tournament was won by tigran
petrossian one full point ahead of uh
mikhail thali and boris posky
but you know it's not not an easy task
winning the the ussr championship
but you know scoring second place uh
tied with
with uh uh boris posky uh definitely
definitely a a victory in itself
uh and also there is one one um a photo
i wanted to show you it's uh
actually from this tournament it's from
uh uh from the
uh analysis of the final game between uh
uh between mikael tal and mark taimanov
uh they're analyzing their game it ended
in a draw
but you can see how how how good a photo
it is you we don't have many photos of
this championship i'm sure
there are some somewhere there are these
photos that they exist
somewhere on the internet but
very hard to find i i think i i found
this one on uh
olympia urkan's uh twitter twitter feed
uh so thanks for that uh so we can enjoy
at least uh
some of the imagery uh that uh of what
happened there
so yeah that's the game uh hope you guys
enjoyed it really a wild one
and uh yeah there are still are a lot of
tournaments that we have to cover this
being one of them as
you can if you you know so so many great
games played here
uh we will we will cover all of them at
some point but you know
we'll see we'll see how it goes uh so
once again if you guys are interested
this is the
the big big fellow uh the youtube golden
youtube play button
there we have it really i want strategy
doesn't doesn't even fit in the screen
there we have it
uh and yeah uh
i hope you guys enjoyed the game i i
i searched uh for quite a while to
decide which game to show and there are
so many of them
uh but it's uh it's it's a very special
feeling when uh when misha defeats a
player uh such as uh pologevsky because
he he's just super strong and he doesn't
uh you know he doesn't just cover up
when you attack him he fights back he's
also a great
uh attacking player himself and i
thought that this one
this one was more more than fitting uh
so
uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it one more time i would like to
thank frank combs uh john nicely sudden
uh uranthal and robert smitters for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
thank you once again for helping this
channel
uh reach this magical number of 1
million subscribers
uh see you soon